[Music]
everyone's buying and wrapping gifts
right now and holiday wrapping paper as
you can imagine it's a huge business
well actually we went out we found some
gift wrap that hasn't sold very well
this year so right now we're just gonna
take a quick look at holiday wrapping
paper that nobody wanted for example
here's our first wrapping paper it's
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
completely shaved for ticks
I mean aesthetically not pleasing but
probably a wise decision
Rudolph's part here's an other wrapping
paper nobody wanted I think I understand
why it's Santa with his seat his second
secret family in Toledo here's one I
think I understand why this didn't go
it's an x-ray of a candy cane lodged
inside someone's colon
hey they they took it difficult and
first yeah I know they did they have
some professional work yeah there's an
easier way to do that they didn't do it
here's one I don't just I like this one
here's Gary Busey decorating his tree
with me I like that one this one yeah I
can see why this didn't sell it's just
sad it's kids in Africa watching Santa
fly past them
terrible thing to wrap a present it's
just awful
oh why anyone would do that I don't know
why that company did that ah I hate that
company here's here's one that didn't go
mrs. Claus in a broken bathroom stall no
boy being walked in on these are just
terrible and all just awful a company
not us not company would make such tract
such downright trash right
and finally this one I don't understand
this at all because I want this check it
out it's snowmen with Scottie Pippen's
head
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Merry Christmas and you I never open it
we'll be right back